yeah
everyone welcome to the fourth day of
the beyond the bullion Workshop so our
first pick for the day is Dan McQueen so
and he's going to talk about stochastic
approach for noise stability so take it
away then
[Music]
so hi good morning
and
um it's kind of a long title and it's
not really the title and which appears
in the schedule
really the point is to talk about noise
stability
um
on the cube
and and somehow to go beyond the Boolean
Cube and somehow they feel
of the workshop and
um I should say that this is Joint work
with
and I think oh well at least he
mentioned it briefly in the boot camp
you had like two or three weeks ago so
hopefully I can give a bit more details
than what toonan said
and also it's maybe I should mention
that this is a project that originally
um was initiated in the Simons Institute
so it's nice to talk about it here okay
so let's just take a quick outline of
what we're going to do and I'm going to
quickly recap on noise stability on the
definition and and then mention you know
one of the major
[Music]
um
motivations to this work
in the form of you know one of the most
well known field and in this uh those
concept is the majority established
theorem
somehow um we found a new a new pool for
that theorem with better quantitative
dependencies
unfortunately I'm not going to show the
entire proof here I'm just going to show
like a proof of a much much easier
problem but hopefully it will give like
the major and the ideas so
I I'll explain the approach and then
I'll use it to to solve like a toy
problem and surprisingly this toy
problem also turns out to be interesting
in its own right and then if I have some
time left I'll say something about
majority Stables okay
and feel free to interrupt me at any
point
hopefully everything is mostly
self-contained
so
noise stability
to Define no stability on the hypercube
without the hypercube
dimensions
and mu will just be the uniform measure
on it for the talk
and we have the noise operators it's a
semi-group of operators parameterized by
the noise noise between zero and one
positive for the talk
and it's an operator of on functions it
takes a function returns a new function
and what it does to this new function
well it takes the original function and
it integrates it around the cube
with respect to a correlated measure so
here Y is a binary string it is
correlated with X with correlation row
okay
basically it means that y has a product
distribution
and at each
coordinate it is has low correlation
with X okay
in other words it is the unique product
measure which has a
expectation of x
okay so that's the that's the noise
operator
you know no stability the probability of
a function and and we'll think about it
as a probability for Boolean functions
so you take your function f
you smooth it so you add noise to it by
applying the noise operator zero and you
check how correlated they are
Okay so
it's not how to see that this is a value
between zero and one if this is a
Boolean function
and well it measures how
how noise affects your function okay by
adding noise how much does the value of
the function change with respect to the
original value it'll save okay and one
way in which I like to think about it is
like f is a voting function
the the coordinates of the Boolean cubes
or votes
every every Dimension cuts a vote
and you get to decide to make one
decision
either yes or no depending on all the
votes you've seen
and noise stability says well how
how much is your voting system
suspectable to noise right if I allow
you to flip some code and I can really
change the outcome or not
right so here is a very very I mean I
think one of the first example which
shows the importance
um of noise stability for social Choice
Theory I I I won't you know
say too much about the details but the
point is if you use the Boolean function
to run between three candidates so you
need to
you have three candidates
a b and c and you somehow use your
Boolean function to rank them and you
want to say
well a is better than b and then B is
better than C and of course a is also
better than Siri then this is a rational
outcome because it's transitive and an
irrational outcome would be
something which contradicts
right and if you just use a Boolean
function to run three candidate and you
draw your your votes randomly from the
cube then maybe you would get an
irrational outcome and actually a rose
Paradox for most functions you will get
an irrational outcome with some
probability and this can be Quantified
and this is a theorem of gay current it
still can be Quantified by the noise
stability with some some noise level
Okay so
it's a very nice result
and and with this perspective
there is a there is a natural question
to ask
if we look on all possible Boolean
function and let's normalize it
let's introduce some normalization just
the balance which means that the
expectation is zero they have equal
chance of giving ones an equal chance of
giving minus one and which function
maximizes the noise stability
what is the most stable voting system
which which function maximizes the
probability to get the rational outcome
and I mean if you know something about
arrows paradox
there's only one function which can
maximize it
kind of unfortunate and this is the
dictator
so this has an easy answer
among all Boolean functions the dictate
or the Boolean function which ignores
all the coordinates and just looks at
the single coordinate has the largest
noise stability
so I mean it's an easy answer and it's
easy to describe it it's also an easy
proof you can simply diagonalize the
noise operators the monomials or the
eigenfunctions and this corresponds to
the minimal eigen value
but I mean it's not a very useful fact
if you want to design a good voting
system
in some circles
but the reason it's not a it's not a
useful fact is that you know intuitively
we'd want to roll out functions which
behave like this so in other words we
want to rule out functions
which only depend on a small number of
coordinates
so
well how how can we quantify that
we can introduce the maximal influence
right here
this stands for the partial derivative
of the Boolean function f partial
discrete derivative in Direction I
simply
now what happens when you keep all code
in its fixed and you just flip the ifb
that's the function change values or
does not change values
it's a fancy way to write what is the
probability of the function changing
value when you just click the ibif this
is the influence in the ith Direction
and the maximal influence well is the
maximum overall all directions right so
obviously this has a high influence
because whenever you change the first
beef the first bit then the value of the
function changes and every function
which is which only depends on a small
number option or that will also have a
high maximal influence so somehow having
a small maximal influence Quantified how
high dimensional build function is and
how you know
how
social like the social benefits of not
allowing a small group to decide or a
small junta
right so so now we can refine the
question and ask among all balanced
Boolean function with small maximal
influence which one maximizes the noise
stability
okay and now the answer is much much
nicer
both from the function to actually
maximizes it but also from the proof and
this is a
this is the majority of stable theorem
of the most
from almost 2 20 years ago
right and and the
the
statement is that for a like if you take
any balanced Boolean function and you
impose the constraint that all the
inferences are bounded by some parameter
Kappa foreign
stability of f is bounded by some
function of the noise
plus some evil term and the error term
I mean it's quantitative and it goes to
zero as Kappa goes to zero but it goes
to zero slowly
right if you take Kappa to zero then
this quantity goes to zero
the reason it is called majority is
Stables is that well you can look at the
majority function
just check if you have more ones or more
minus ones
you have more ones than the sum will be
positive if you have more minus one then
sum will be negative and well this has
no bearing on the outcome but it should
be suggestive
and no simply by symmetry is a very easy
calculation shows that
the maximal influence of majority goes
to zero
they mentioned increases
it's not surprising I mean that's what
you would expect and a slightly just
slightly more involved calculation using
the central image theorem because you
can see that this converges to a
gaussian allows you to quantify the
noise stability of majority in the limit
right and in the limit
this is exactly the noise stability of
majority which justifies the name
majority is Stables up to an additive
level
you don't you know yeah I mean since
you're taking sign
then it is exactly the same it's just be
suggestive because I will still Center
limits together
but it really has no bearing
any other questions
and maybe a sketch really briefly
um
the original proof of majority
established both because it's so nice
and also because it is somehow relevant
to what I'm going to say next
so the idea is
to reduce everything to gaussian space
okay so in gaussian space you can
replace the noise semi group
foreign
the majority function which is
essentially an indicator of over half
space
it becomes an indicator of the half
and then the analog domination of noise
stability
by this of the semigroup by an indicator
of our space is just there is a
parametric inequality in the gaussian
space so that was known for
since the 70s probably
but now we want so that's a result in
gout and switch now we want to reduce
things to gaussian space and this is
the major theorem
ooo paper this is the invariance
principle they prove an invariance
principle for low degree polynomials
basically
if you take any polynomial on the
hypercube and you compare
the polynomial in gaussian space
if the polynomial has small maximal
influence it behaves basically the same
ingots in space and in the hypercube
so long as it has a small degree
right so
somehow this is I mean incompatible with
what we had before because majority of
an indicator of a high stress is not a
load I mean every function is a
polynomial on the hyper tube but not
every function is a low degree
polynomial and in particular the degree
of majority will be much larger than how
much they influence the case right so
that's not good enough
foreign
your Boolean function by some smoothing
units smoothing version of it which is
just what you achieve by applying the
noise operator and what the noise
operator does it attenuates the high
frequencies and it essentially makes any
High degree or any polynomial into an
essentially low degree polynomial but
you know all you did for the noise
stability is simply added more noise so
instead of calculating the noise
stability of your original function you
can calculate the noise stability with a
slightly higher noise level
to the smoothed out version and get some
result and it turns out that the amount
of noise you need to ask is exactly
proportional to the additive error you
have and this is the cause for this
additive level okay
which essentially tells you that any any
proof or majority of stables which goes
through the invariance principle mustn't
call this Arrow
so the quantitative bottleneck is the
quantitative aspects of invariance yes
always
it's supposed to be polynomial I think
foreign
it's okay
okay so I mean that's that's the problem
what's super influential for many
many years and many many
neighboring fields and what I'm not
going to discuss any of the applications
but one thing which you might notice
here is that
this goes to zero very very slowly we
might you might want to get a better
quantitative
like dependency in the theorem even
though that I should be honest for most
applications which are asymptotic you're
happy with anything which is little old
one
okay and then basically what we proved
is a quantitative version of majority is
stables and it can replace here the sub
logarithmic dependence with the
polynomial dependence and
essentially
the defendant Swagat is Kappa
one minus 4 times some small constant
and up to that small constant for some
noise levels this is optimal
and
otherwise it's exactly the same just the
noise level changed
and one way to
discard the difference of our
this is what I want to discuss later on
from the original proof is that
in some sense the original proof looks
at the expect the noise stability of f
tells it slightly further and then looks
at the noise stability of the smoothed
out version of it so in some sense
you're looking at the noise stability
as a function of law right you have a
some expectation
this is a function of raw and you're
asking how how much does this function
of law evolve like when you increase the
volume by a bit
and what we did we kind of refined this
point of view and when we said let's
find some stochastic process
which gives this function as a
measurement
and then let's study the past
of these stochastic process so you get a
lot more information
then when you take expectation well you
already know so much that you know you
get a trivial inequality once you take
an expectation right so basically
instead of moving an inequality
the level of the expectation improve an
inequality in the level of the process
itself a process which is parameterized
by the noise level then you can simply
take expectations right so somehow we
get final control
and we get to bypass the involence
principle
which is uh which is nothing even right
we actually use an Ito process to do it
which allows us to use stochastic
analysis
um to analyze it
and and you know a nice by-product from
development is that we we found okay we
constructed the new marketing a new
Martingale way to embed
the
hypercube has a Brownian motion
so
introduction let me explain the
approach
so okay
maybe before they say something about
the approach so we have a function on
the hypercube and I said I'm going to
realize the function and some Brownian
motion
but
this is defined on the hypercube on the
discrete Cube the bone in motion is a
continuous thing so we need to find a
way to extend this
from the Boolean Cube to go
see what they did there
and to go to the continuous Cube
and so there are many many ways to
extend the function from the Boolean
Cube to The Continuous Cube but since we
want to work with a bone in motion we
want to walk with the mouth angle
specifically there is one canonical way
to do it in this case and this is to
take the harmonic extension
and you can
describe it in in many different ways
but the I mean easiest way to describe
it you have a function from the Boolean
Cube
it's polynomials you can write it as a
polynomial X1 okay
then you can forget that those are
Boolean variables and simply three them
as continuous variables right we like to
call it inside the pulling inside of it
we thought initially we thought to a
free Workshop inside Beyond and I mean
this also works Beyond right
this also goes beyond the Boolean Cube
you won't do it
but we should
so that's the easiest way to define it
like the harder way it solves the
dirichlet problem on the hypercube
the the ad hoc way to define it
is
for an inner function
in the solid cube right so if x is a
Boolean string when you multiply it by
row you get something within the cube
then you simply Define it as the noise
operator of f applied to that function
right in some sense
instead of integrating something or
there's some correlated Vector in the
cube you simply evaluate some extension
in the interior of the cube
so this is the haddock definition
and and here is here is the observation
now
let's define a new measure on the solid
cube
it's basically the uniform measure on
the hypercube but the dilated version of
it
and then
what happens for noise stability noise
stability is the correlation of f with
its noisy version but its noisy version
it's just an evaluation of f of its
extension right so I'm going to identify
evidence extension inside an interior
point of the cube
now turns out well this is a semi group
it's a cell for joint semigo so you can
take one square root of here and move it
to here I mean this is a fact so this is
simply an equality but now what happens
here we're simply evaluating the
harmonic extension of f
against itself so it's no longer I mean
it's no linear correlation it's an L2
Norm but not with respect to the uniform
measure on the Boolean Cube but we
expect to the uniform measure on some
dilated
human that depends on the noise level
right so we've I mean I mean this is
completely tautologies but we'll simply
reload the noise stability of f as an L2
Norm with respect to some other measure
and this suggests
you know a way to maybe try and
generalize the definition of noise
stability is let's take any measure on
minus one one
right and let's define the noise
stability of f with respect to that
measures you know take the product
measure of new with some measure or
minus one minus
so anyway this is a measure one minus
one line so discrete measure so take its
product and calculate the noise
stability of f with respect to that new
sorry calculate the L2 Norm of f with
respect to this new measure and you know
this seems like we've created a new
thing here because there was a lot of
flexibility in choosing this measure new
but it turns out that you know nothing
special happened
I mean it's an easy proof just by taking
an octogonal decomposition of the rel2
and basically when we write the noise
stability with respect to an arbitrary
measure of the new
but with the Imagine U of f it simply
reduces to the original measure of noise
stability
but the noise level is just the variance
of you try to hear the variance of New
Israel so the variance of this measure
is wrong
and this will be two for any other
measure okay so again
everything here are the autologies I
haven't really said anything I've just
Rewritten the same thing in like three
different ways but but now I mean we get
a strategy from that
because now
what would be the idea let's find a
sequence of measures
path of measures or stochastic process
and calculate the noise stability with
respect to that stochastic process
and as long as the variance of the
process starts from zero and goes all
the way to one for any intermediate
value we will get something and then
we'll simply need to analyze that
process
so here is the process
right it's an
Ito process it's a melting girl
if you B is a Brownian motion
in the cube it starts from zero
and X is a need to process you simply
take the burning motion and you
renormalize its variance at every step
so Sigma here is a matrix
you take it as a diagonal matrix when
you take the ergonometrics you are
scaling each code in it separately so
the coordinates of this process are
independent it's how many dimensions
okay so in the dimension of the cube
it's simply going to be a process in the
solid cube and the idea is that it will
be a Martingale it will stop on the
vertices of the diskette Cube so at time
Infinity it will be uniformly
distributed
so the idea is to take the solid the
Boolean Cube and embed it into RN and
some will take the measure the universal
on it and embed it into the path of the
Browning motion
so here Sigma T is a is a diagonal
matrix
every coordinate depends only on the I
the iPhone
the I diagonal entry depends only on the
I
entry of the process right so everything
really is independent
and what happens here basically you
check whether your coordinates
approaches a facets
and the closer it is to a facet the
slower that coordinate moves
right the closer it is to one the
smaller this is the closer so the closer
this is together because this is the one
the slower the move or the probability
is to minus one
did you have this particular
sorry did you guess this particular for
me
um
a lot of trial and error but but I I I I
I will I will explain why
would this work with other Slowdown
no
no I I will explain why I mean
you can always take a time change and
then do the analysis on the time change
space but somehow this is canonical in
the following sense which is irrelevant
to the poof but um
someone which explains why resources
make sense is if you measure the
enthalpy of the process it is the unique
process in which the entropy Decay is a
linear
ly concentrated
but he was talking about polarizing
random works right so this is
yes
but not the same okay
but yeah okay so so there are some
properties of that process which you
like let's say one in a second
really it's the other properties which
matter
but but let's start with something very
simple
right so we can now look at at the
measure which is the law of one
coordinate at time T so what's Time Zero
I mean it's a Delta measure at zero
because the process starts from zero it
has a variance zero
it's a marketing girl you can see that
it can never leave the Boolean queue
because once you reach a facet you stop
Before Time Infinity but that doesn't
really matter but at time Infinity
because it's a Martingale every code and
it still has expectation zero it is uh
it's a product measure so it's time
Infinity it is uniform on the cube which
means that the variance of TX time
Infinity is one
and at every intermediate time it
interprets between zero one you can
actually write a formula for it right
one minus
something which decays exponentially
within I mean it's a calculation to
prove that you can simply use it as
formula
to write what is the second moment of X
you get some differential equation and
calculate that that won't really matter
for anything
but here are some nice facts
so if you look at the terminal point of
the path which is just uniformly
distributed
minus one one or on the cube and you
condition on everything you've seen up
to time t
and this is a uniform so this is a
random measure you can define y t to
have this random law
so
every time txt is just the expectation
of this random law which doesn't I mean
that's doesn't really say anything it
just says that this is a mounting gun
right when you take expectation of a
mountain girl you get what you've
conditioned on but the nice thing is
that if you if you want to ask what is
the covariance of your random random
Vector then this is exactly the Matrix
Sigma thing
so
at every point
you renormalize by the amount of
variance you have left
until you reach there until you reach
the end of the path
we call it a real normalized
and now here is the point
if we take now any Boolean function f
we extend it harmonically on the solid
cube well we get
an harmonic function
when you apply a harmonic function to a
Martingale you get a melt angle
so let's call this multiple NT
we got some Martingale
on the interval minus one one
and you can you know you can analyze its
path
well you can ask what is the noise
stability of f
with respect to some noise level just
the variance
of the process here
products this is exactly the identity we
had before
it's the L2 Norm of f with respect to
Newton right so you simply take F
evaluate it on the random Vector x t
that's the L2 Norm here and T is just
the Martingale and
is an easy way to say harmonic
it would be true for any harmonic
function but
and in stochastic calculus like the nice
way to say L2 Norm here is the quadratic
variation of
the mountain but I mean if you're not
comfortable with it or processes then
you continue to think about the L to
know
and you know what do we do in the proof
so here f is an arbitrary Boolean
function we take another multiple empty
to represents
the noise stability of majority
because NT represents the noise
stability of the Boolean function f
and then what we do we prove an
inequality
in the level of path right we prove that
there is some coupling between n and M
such as the quadratic variation of the
square of M dominates the square of n
almost Julie
and then right when you take an
expectation here and when you take an
expectation here obviously you get an
inequality for the expectation
so we put an inequality on the level of
paths and then when you take an
expectation you get an inequality for
the noise stability
of course this is this is way too much
to hope for
right because then you would get an
exact domination for any Boolean
function by the majority so you know
there's actually some error term we
prove here and it's actually two only up
to certain times
and this is why I can present the entire
proof
foreign
[Music]
but
I mean
that's a very good question it would be
helpful me to this thing but to get this
inequality that inequality basically you
get here in evil term it depends on the
influence yes and what we really do we
prove and if we choose a good direction
on the hypercube on the solid cube okay
project those two guides to the random
Direction and we apply a central limit
theorem in that direction
and then if you have no influences you
can simply use the reassing and
Dimension One
so you don't even any sophisticated
everything depends on having low
influences
will basically be the maximum influence
any other questions
oh
Okay so
let's let's use this approach to prove
something easy
clearly
so among all balanced Boolean functions
no other constraints
the dictator maximizes noise stability
right so it has a very very easy
Applause
diagonalize the noise operator that's
not much of that
right
so
as before we have now an arbitrary
Boolean function
yeah
and we have G which is just the dictator
and somehow we will want to compare the
path
of NT which is f applied to that process
to the renormalized bound and motion
and well empty which is the dictator
applied to the same process it's time
too and well we simply look at the first
coordinate
right and here we will really find the
coupling between n and M
such that this is to almost truly
without an error term because it is
really true that the dictator maximizes
noise stability among all Boolean
functions so this will be a strict
inequality
and so how do you do that now we can do
some calculations
this will be the only calculations I do
so empty
right it's a some stochastic it's an
auto process it's a function it's a
multilinear function applied to an E2
process you can use you can use each of
the formula to write it and you know
that it's a Martingale so it will be
something times the Brownian motion so
I'm Vector times the boundary motion and
you know by the chain rule that Vector
is just the first derivative of G
single is a fancy name politics formula
but J is the dictator
so its first derivative is just in just
one on the first coordinate and zero
amplifier so you simply recover the
first coordinate of the Matrix scale
times DBT
now when you take the square when you
take the quadratic variation you take
that refractor for the burning motion
and you square it and you forget about
the wrong emotion this is the basic rule
of Vito calculus
right so the time derivative of the
quadratic variation is the square of the
volatility here which is 1 minus Mt
square right this is exactly empty it's
the dictator of applied to the process
and
very very hard formula to go from here
to here and
the point is that we see that the square
of empty satisfies the differential
equality
now what can we do
for the other process and which is more
arbitrary well we can do the same thing
right data differential take the square
right and you simply get the square of
the
gradient of f so this is the gradient of
the harmonic extension times The Matrix
Sigma TN but when you open it up this is
exactly the expression you get
right so
same thing here but you
re-way as a coordinate by the partial
derivative of f in that direction
and here is here is the only point
where where we use the properties of the
process because this is basically two
would be two for every other process
with the different
reflector here is that you have an
almost sure inequality
for that quantity
right you can
this turns out to be just the the loyal
Fourier coefficient with respect to a
biased measure which has exactly this
expectation
equality it will be smaller by the L2
Norm of the same function
I'm skipping it but this is this is just
a calculation
which you do on the biased Cube
and and this is the only process which
will afford this inequality
right so you get that
the time derivative of the quadratic
variation of n is smaller
well by 1 minus n t squared
basically we get a differential
inequality for empty we got a
differential equality
for NT we get the same thing by by as a
strict inequality okay it's strict
unless this is the big title
so
I mean we have those two things how can
we combine them together now we want to
find the coupling and use this fact to
show that this thing is always smaller
than this thing
so here is here is a way to find the
coupling both NT and empty are one
dimensional Mountain girls
and you know it's a fact
any one dimensional Martingale is a
stretched Brownian motion
right so there exists a Brownian motion
let's call it w completely unrelated to
the previous bone in motion such that if
you stop it at a random time and the
random time is exactly the quadratic
variation of n where you simply get the
law of M basically the amount of
variance you need the first of the
bottom motion is basically the variance
of the post of the random variable you
need to achieve and this is true for the
entire path
so there exists about an motion so that
you can embed the entire marketing and
into its path and the exists a burning
motion another bone and motion that you
can embed the other Mountain girl
um into its path
and then you can take the two bound and
motions to be the same
so basically this is a way to couple
the two mountain girls
in the same probability space
now
now let's reverse words let's fix the
time Tau
and ask when we look at this bone and
motion W which is the same here in the
same here
this time fixed time Tau how far did n
get and how far did M get right so this
is the random time for nt1 and this is
the random time for M T2 I think and
this is just if you think about it this
is just the inverse of the quadratic
variation and this is the index for the
quadratic variation of M
but the reinverses we we want to look at
the time derivatives right so we have
the inverse function field and
and derivative of that will be 1 over
the derivative of the quadratic
variation we've calculated that we have
a differential equality
right and no this is again just the bone
of motion at the time so
and for the other process we have a
differential inequality
we reversing all so the direction of the
inequality changes
and when you combine everything together
we see that you know one random time
always evolves smaller at a smaller rate
than the other random time
which means that you know one of them is
always smaller than the other and those
are the inverse functions right this is
the inverse function of the quadratic
variation which tells us that the
quadratic variation of M is always under
the scaffolding is always louder than
the quadratic variation of N and again
now we can take an expectation
and we get this spoof
very complicated proof of this very
simple fact
okay but this is this is basically the
idea
you want to prove an
almost true inequality or at least an
inequality in a very high probability
that we actually could poop on those two
in quality and you can simply take
expectation and get something
okay so so that was a complicated book
of uh of an easy fact but we actually
get more
so so now if we take and this is the
what we get here if we take any function
Phi
which is a convex function right so for
example if we take Phi to be the square
well we just move that m t is the
expectation of Mt squared is always
larger than the expectation of entities
but you can take any convex function
if you take any convex function and
apply it to empty well it's the same as
applying the convex function to the
bologna motion at the random time which
is the quadratic variation
and well we know that this time is
always larger than the other time we
proved it so we can condition on it
and this is a Martingale it's a Brownian
motion right so when we and and we apply
to it a convex function so simply by
Johnson's inequality we can take
everything inside condition on that
thing here
and get Phi applied to the bologna
motion at a smaller time and that's one
of the time exactly corresponds to n so
not only do we pull the noise stability
of M is always larger than the next
relatability of n we prove that this is
also true for any other convex function
and this is not something you can get
from diagonalization
and there is one convex function of the
interest
which is the binary enthalpy function
and if we apply the binary entropy
function into here we get that
this just measures
the entropy
of the terminal bit right F applied to X
the time Infinity is a random bits
random uniform bit
so it's the conditional entropy
when you condition everything when the
process up to time t
then when you use this identity
together with this inequality you get
the following results
right you can Define the mutual
information as just the entropy when you
clean for me it's the conditional
entropy
and you get it among all Boolean
function
no other constraints
the dictator maximizes the mutual
information so
you want to learn something about this
random string
you have to do one single measurement
you get to extract one single bit
from its terminal point what is the best
bit you can use which is the best
measurement you can do in order to
extract the most information I mean just
the trivial thing
just look at the first code in it
that would give you the most information
and I mean the thing to compare it to
is to the most informative bit
conjecture of Tom Cruise
goes by and the Kumar
and Dell conjecture is that among all
Boolean functions the dictator maximizes
the mutual information in the following
sense right again you have a Boolean so
you have a you have a Boolean string
you can take one measurement but the
difference is that here Y is a low
correlated Vector of X in the same sense
of the noise stability thank you
this is still a correlated version of X
but the correlation structure is
basically different it's not as
homogeneous
as here
so I mean that
complicated buffer so it basically
proves
a version
of this conjecture with respect
to a different noise model
and I mean this is this is all
this is open for
nine years now and there have been many
many results but it's still open in full
generality more about what the
difference is yeah I mean
The Joint law
that's an excellent question the The
Joint law of X and its law correlated
Vector Y is simply not the joint law of
the terminal point
and the the intermediate Point here
so let's see the product distribution
right so every coordinating sounds they
don't they don't they don't have the
same uh right they can be different
places so it can be different
correlation yeah exactly so the point is
if you could if you if you could
follows the process to stop
at that it's an inner tube and then put
the same thing and this would exactly
give people multiple type but so now we
don't know whether the process is going
to move so explain the point inside
it's not available
it doesn't quantify the noise
but it's constructed in a way that there
are two nodes are the same so any L2
quantity is good for us entropy is not
available
foreign
why those two theorems are different
I mean so not to feel them the theorem
is different from the conjecture
so in some sense
in a very very vague sense this is more
canonical than this
and why is that
basically we have here an inequality for
any convex function
between
so it doesn't have to be L2 and it
doesn't have to be entropy and it's true
that if you I mean if you replace here
something which corresponds to the
dictator and here's just any Boolean
function it's not there is a convex
function so that there is some Boolean
function which dominates The Dictator
so this inequality we proved here
is too strong
to actually prove the full Command put
that conjunction
anything we want to prove
we need to
change
the process somehow I mean if it could
work and you know hope for Less
a weaker inequality that's something
which is almost too
five minutes left
let's say something quick about majority
is stabless
this is what we wanted to prove
and you know to recap the Main
Ingredients we had from before and how
they fit into the new picture now we
have a melting Ln which is the harmonic
extension of a Boolean function now with
small influences applied to the process
we'll have a different marketing LM
to represent the noise stability of
majority right so we wanted to have an
L2 Norm
which is this Alex sign
will prove a differential equality for n
and we'll put a differential inequality
for n and we'll use the same idea to
couple them
okay so I mean here is n we defined it
we also need to Define m and what we
want for men basically well we wanted to
represent the noise stability of
majorities
there are infinitely many ways to get
such a mouthing girl
but
we also want a Martingale such that we
can compare its paths
I mean one one possibility is to take
just majority apply to our posts so this
should be extinct so we should take
majority apply to the process X still
the same way we took the Boolean
function apply to XC but this is this is
not I mean this would depend on the
dimension on one hand so it's not very
canonical and the other end it will not
give exactly this because this is this
is only the noise stability of majority
in the limits
and on the other hand really the reason
why majority establishes two is because
it's two in gaussian space
so so the idea is to compare everything
to gaussian space right so instead we
take a sort of a limiting object in
gaussian space
and
I mean really we want something to
capture the iso perimetric profile
of the Galaxy this is this is the reason
for for the majority Stables
so this is the iso parametric profile of
the gaussian right it's the
Windows CDF or the quantile function
composed with its density
and it's exactly the
exactly the surface area of a hyperplane
or even volume would be given gaussian
volume and well we can Define
empty to Simply evolve with a boundary
motion according to this to this
function right so again this is a
function which is 0 or minus one and one
sorry on zero and one but there is we
will scale it
so after rescaling this will never leave
the interval and it slows down the
closer you get to the edges
and I mean the main idea is that
after everything I said hopefully it's
not surprising is that if you check the
quadratic variation it exactly encodes
the noise stability of majority in the
limit so this exactly equals this ALK
sign
some functionality
and automatically we get the
differential equality for M to Simply
take the square of that that's the time
derivative of the quadratic variation
so the main technical point is to prove
a differential equality differential
inequality for M and basically we prove
that
if
like NT is f the element extension
applied to the process the time T and if
F has a small
um influences then with high probability
this inequality holds
it's exact it satisfies like if you
forget about that forget about that it
is almost the same equation
there is some error term which depends
on the quadratic variation but sorry
over over the processors
right this is a this is a random
quantity and this is a random quantity
and
so it's not an honesty but it's enough
and when this is polynomial in Kappa so
when you integrate it all the later on
you get a polynomial
I should maybe also say that this is
only two up to some stopping time
it can't be too for all times but
because
basically here this c times Kappa is the
is the maximal influence of the function
f
not with respect to the uniform measure
because everything shifts now with time
so it is with respect to the measure
from the bias measure on the hypercube
which has expectation X
closer you get to a vertex
the less you will be able to expect to
have small influences everywhere
right but you know for most times this
is to and you get this inequality and
this is enough to actually integrate it
later on
yeah and
as I said earlier the entire proof
relies
on writing the quadratic variation
and some one-dimensional measurement
basically in the direction of the
gradient of F and then apply a central
image field and yeah
foreign
for that
thank you for listening
[Applause]
any questions for them
ladies version
like for your proficient found is there
influence bounds it does this
because if it's essentially
consists a little small
foreign
what other methods
but definitely
because I'm wearing with these things
for more than for three functions
you mean like not on the Boolean Cube
but uh F3 I guess
that's a good question so somehow
like the point here is that we can embed
the cube into our end and preserve the
structure
so for example you could
take a foreign
[Music]
The Complex Community products of
so so if it's like F3 it's a triangle so
yeah there's
another normal questions
done again
[Applause]
and we come back in 30 minutes